from Hannibal's tastiest meal preps to
slip in Jimmy's messiest exploits these
shows are proof that some TV prequels
are even better than the stories they
came from
a prequel to a reboot Caprica hit
screens in 2010 a year after the
dramatic ending of Science Fiction drama
Battle Star Galactica Battlestar had
been a relaunch of a short-lived sci-fi
Adventure from 1978 with producer Ronald
D Moore turning the campy family
adventure into a gritty War story that
dazzled audiences with dark sobering
storylines and unpredictable twists and
turns Caprica was entirely different a
Sci-Fi political thriller set decades
earlier on a thriving world where AI
technology is in its infancy taking
place nearly 60 years before the Earth
Cylon war of BSG the show explored the
relationship between two rival families
the greystones and the Adamas and saw
the Advent of the technology that would
lead to the Cylon race I'm Zoe and the
Avatar and the robot like some kind of
what you call a three-parter trinity
starring Eric Stoltz and isai Morales as
family Patriarchs Daniel Greystone and
Joseph Adama respectively the series set
itself apart from BSG with a focus on
political and religious Intrigue and
profound personal drama
what would you do if you had the chance
to to be with your daughter again packed
with social allegory Caprica garnered
Rey reviews from critics the guardian
called the series dense and intelligent
sci-fi complex bizarre and ambitious
despite the Acclaim Caprica lasted just
a single season but it's remained a cult
favorite ever since
a Batman prick will arrived in 2014 in
the form of Gotham a grim hard-boiled
crime series set in the city Batman
would one day protect Bruce
my name is Bruce Wayne
in it Bruce Wayne is a young boy so the
series focuses more on Gotham PD
Lieutenant James Gordon played by Ben
McKenzie and his efforts to combat the
city's criminal Underworld the series
opened with the killing of Gotham
socialites Thomas and Martha Wayne
as the show progressed audiences met
many of Batman's eventual Rogues Gallery
with future Villains The Penguin
Catwoman The Riddler and the Joker
making appearances as well as several
new baddies like Jada Pinkett Smith as
Fish Mooney
only my friends
call me fish praised for its slick
production and stylish storytelling
Gotham ran for Five Seasons ending with
a now adult Bruce Wayne donning Cape and
Cowell to become The Dark Knight
The Big Bang Theory was a multi-camera
sitcom about three geeky friends in
Pasadena who fill their days with video
games comic books and RPGs there's just
some quantum mechanics with a little
String Theory doodling around the edges
that part there that's just a joke it's
a spoof of the born Oppenheimer
approximation a Smash Hit for 12
astonishing Seasons Big Bang became a
franchise in 2017 with the debut of
prequel series young Sheldon about the
awkward youth of child prodigy Sheldon
young actor Ian Armitage plays Sheldon
whose trials and tribulations include
skipping four grades this makes him a
social misfit and yet occasionally a
hero him being so young isn't like weird
I'm basically 50. and we're basically 12
so it all works out balancing a tough
school schedule with problems at home he
also has to deal with the frustrations
of having a dimmer-witted older brother
morning I slept in the nude last night
fell every little breeze
a heartfelt and heartwarming family
sitcom that brings a fresh angle to the
character with stories about Sheldon's
social struggles young Sheldon was a big
hit with Indie wire calling out its
strong mix of comedy and drama and its
empathetic approach to the central
character
Perry Mason began in the 1930s as a
series of novels by Earl Stanley Gardner
before becoming a series of films a
radio drama and eventually a hit TV
series starring Raymond Burr that ran
for nearly 300 episodes beginning in
1957 revived briefly in the 1970s as the
new Perry Mason Burr returned to the
role for a series of TV movies all the
way through the 1990s no further
questions
after a decades-long absence the
unflappable lawyer reappeared in the
2020 prequel series Perry Mason starring
Matthew Reese you were in the war were
you the way you hold your cigarette
hiding The Unborn I guess I'm still
trying not to give him something to
shoot this series takes place years
before Mason becomes a lawyer in this
darker drama Mason is a beleaguered
private investigator whose business is
struggling during the Great Depression
the series first season tells a single
story across Eight Episodes as Mason
investigates a grisly child murder case
the show's strongest asset might be its
phenomenal cast which includes Tatiana
maslani and John Lithgow among many
other standouts graced for its
sophisticated story compelling mystery
evocative style and overall Panache
Harry mason built off Decades of
previous stories to provide a new spin
on an old classic
born from the mind of Muppets Creator
Jim Henson The Dark Crystal was an
iconic 80s family fantasy film full of
ancient relics and mystical Powers it
became an enduring cult classic thanks
to its incredible design captivating
story and blend of lighthearted
playfulness with a foreboding sense of
Doom though there was talk of a sequel
for years a prequel eventually
materialized The Dark Crystal the age of
resistance released in 2019 as a Netflix
original the series was helmed by action
director Louis La terrier and boasted an
All-Star cast voicing its Ensemble of
puppet actors including Mark Hamill
Taryn Edgerton Aquafina Jason Isaacs and
Helena Bonham Carter he's the world's
greatest puppeteers working with new
literary the brilliant director it's a
look that you've never seen before set
long before the events of the film age
of resistance sees a group of childlike
gelflings on a journey to unite their
people to fight back against the devious
and tyrannical geeksies that rule them
the series delivered a powerful Story of
Friendship loyalty and indomitable
Spirit gorgeously produced with
Sumptuous visuals and a story that
expanded on Henson's original The Dark
Crystal age of resistance was a magical
treat that did more than Justice to a
classic making for a stellar fantasy
series in its own right
director Peter Jackson's groundbreaking
Lord of the Rings trilogy brought J.R.R
tolkien's fantasy world to the
mainstream in the early 2000s expertly
realized with a lavish production budget
it quickly became iconic always remember
it back to its master
it wants to be found following a Trilogy
of prequels adapted from The Hobbit many
wondered where the franchise would go
next but it would be a decade before
Amazon's rings of power prequel series
landed in 2022 rings of power is set in
the second age of Middle Earth long
before the events of Lord of the Rings
yet includes several crossover
characters notably Immortal elves elrond
and Galadriel as new evil rises in the
East the different races dwarves elves
Hobbits and man prepare to rise up and
meet it head on the series is a visual
treat a true spectacle that brings the
Cinematic experience to the small screen
story-wise it expands upon themes from
Jackson's Trilogy strong performances an
intriguing plot and plenty of surprises
have helped it Garner critical Acclaim
too with variety calling it a perfectly
winning adaptation that unfolds
swashbuckling adventures with clear
reverence and affection for the
considerable Mythos behind it a massive
success for the streaming giant it's
anyone's guess where the series will go
following its debut season but it's
already proven itself a worthy addition
to tolkien's world
in 2001 the comedy troupe known as the
state produced an offbeat comedy film
Wet Hot American Summer that followed
the antics of a group of teen counselors
at a 1980s summer camp members of the
state were joined by a remarkable cast
including young Paul Rudd Bradley Cooper
and Amy Poehler alongside veterans David
Hyde Pierce Molly Shannon and Janine
Garofalo though it flopped in theaters
its surreal humor and raunchy tone made
it a cult classic more than a decade
later in 2015 a prequel series arrived
on Netflix Wet Hot American Summer first
day of camp the entire cast now 15 years
older returned still playing teenagers
in a story set several months before the
film on the first day of camp in 1981
even Rudd Cooper and polar who had since
achieved Mega stardom came back for the
eight episode series with the likes of
Kristen Wiig and Jason Schwartzman
joining them louded by critics for its
wild off-the-wall comedy the show became
a big hit for Netflix in 2 2017 it was
followed by a sequel series wet Hot
American Summer Ten Years Later
Alfred Hitchcock's Psycho was a seminal
1960s Thriller that almost
single-handedly gave rise to the modern
psychological horror genre psycho
centers on a young woman who winds up in
a hotel run by Norman Bates a twisted
madman whose obsession with his own
mother turns him into a killer well a
boy's best friend is his mother a
Hollywood classic and box office smash
it was followed by a few lesser sequels
and a TV movie called Bates Motel in
1987. in 2013 when the title was
repurposed for a prequel television
series starring Freddie Highmore as
young Norman no one had particularly
High Hopes the series introduces a
teenaged Norman whose mother Norma
played by Vera Farmiga purchases a motel
after the death of her husband trouble
strikes when Norma is forced to kill an
attacker leading to a series of
cover-ups and conspiracies that
threatened to expose them both
surrounded by violence Norman's fragile
mental state deteriorates as he slowly
spirals into madness his mother
struggles to deal with his condition
Bates Motel is a riveting psychological
Thriller that ran for Five Seasons you
told her something happens to me when I
black out he said I change that I'm not
myself who am I mother who am I and what
do I do the final season was a
jaw-dropping remake of the original film
the Los Angeles Times called the series
twisty Moody and modern Bates Motel is a
blueprint for how to craft a clever
fresh prequel to an iconic property
the 1991 film Silence of the Lambs
brought author Thomas Harris's novel to
the big screen with a plum
how Clarisse your problem is you need to
get more fun out of life start Anthony
Hopkins gave a spine chilling and Oscar
winning performance as sociopathic
serial killer Hannibal Lecter
technically this was lecter's second big
screen appearance he originally featured
in Michael Mann's 1986 flick Manhunter
Danish actor mass Mickelson took on the
role for a 2013 NBC prequel series
titled Hannibal which chronicled the
years before Lecter was imprisoned for a
series of cannibalistic murders drawing
mostly on material from Harris's novel
red dragon the show saw renowned
psychiatrist Lecter assisting Intrepid
FBI agent Will Graham played by Hugh
Dancy as a criminal profiler
not fond of eye contact I am
eyes are distracting see too much you
don't see enough created by Brian Fuller
the series reimagine the relationship
between the two future adversaries as
Lecter whose murderous inclinations are
explored in secret becomes obsessed with
the young FBI agent it seems you have an
admirer
you think someone sent me in here
because they admire me dark disturbing
and bold Hannibal pushed the boundaries
of network censorship and was rewarded
with universal acclaim
Star Trek had done prequels before with
the 2001 series Enterprise set in the
early days of Starfleet 2017 Star Trek
Discovery also takes place in the past
just a decade before Kirk and Spock and
that show's second season we meet
Captain Pike and the USS Enterprise in
2022 their story spun off into its own
series Star Trek strange new worlds
starring Anson Mount Ethan Peck and
Rebecca Romaine as classic characters
Pike Mr Spock and number one it explored
early missions of the Enterprise that
had only previously been hinted at
joined by a mix of returning franchise
icons like Uhura oh uh can I help
no nurse chapel and Dr umbenga plus new
characters Luanne nooney and Singh
instant Ortegas and andorian engineer
hemmer the series was a retro return to
sci-fi Adventure while Star Trek
Discovery and Star Trek card focused on
darker more adult-themed serialized
stories strange new worlds successfully
recaptured the classic Trek spirit with
family-friendly episodic stories that
took the crew to new worlds each week
with a strong cast and a big budget the
series refreshed the final frontier
strange new worlds was hailed as a
return to form with a stirring mix of
Big Adventure thought-provoking Science
Fiction humor and heart
creating a spin-off of an acclaimed
series can be risky no matter how good
it is it may always live in the shadow
of its parent series such was the
predicament when the 16-time Emmy
award-winning Breaking Bad announced
that supporting star Bob Odenkirk would
lead spin-off series Better Call Saul
the fact that it would be a prequel and
would run alongside the final seasons of
Breaking Bad made it even trickier
let's bring a pub into a hospital what
was I supposed to leave it on his car
but Odin Kirk and series Creator Vince
Gilligan pulled off the impossible what
the hell do you think you're doing I
need salt I need him right now the show
which debuted in 2015 explored more of
unscrupulous lawyer Saul Goodman's Shady
pass and underhanded dealings while
appearances from Giancarlo Esposito as
Gus Fring and Jonathan Banks as Mike
ehrmantrout helped flesh out the
Breaking Bad Universe by enriching old
stories with new context in time the
events of the series caught up with its
predecessor which even allowed for the
brief return of Brian Cranston as Walter
White with a more left of center Vibe
and a colorful cast of quirky eccentric
characters Better Call Saul was a series
with its own identity while still
delivering gut-wrenching nail-biting
crime stories standing on the shoulders
of a giant the series may have soared
even higher with the guardian declaring
it even more profound and outstripping
Gilligan's former Series in nearly every
way
foreign
[Music]